Alors que grand-père creusait dans le sol de la forêt,
les racines m'ont fascinée
et, en dessous, j'ai ensuite appris qu'il y avait le mycélium blanc
et, en dessous, des strates de minéraux rouges et jaunes.
Finalement, grand-père et moi avons sauvé le pauvre chien
mais à ce moment-là, j'ai réalisé
que cette palette de racines et de sols
était la vraie fondation de la forêt.
Je voulais en savoir plus.
J'ai donc étudié la sylviculture.
Mais je me suis vite retrouvée à travailler avec des gens de pouvoir,
responsables de l'exploitation commerciale.
L'ampleur de la coupe des forêts
était alarmante
et j'étais en désaccord avec le rôle que j'y jouais.
Ce n'était pas que cela, la pulvérisation et la coupe des trembles et bouleaux
pour faire de la place à des pins et sapins ayant plus de valeur commerciale
étaient stupéfiantes.
Rien ne semblait pouvoir arrêter cette impitoyable machine industrielle.
Je suis retournée à l'école
et j'ai étudié mon autre monde.
Les scientifiques venaient de découvrir in vitro dans un laboratoire
que la racine d'un plant de pin
pouvait transmettre du carbone à la racine d'un autre plant.
Mais cela était fait en laboratoire
et je me demandais si c'était aussi vrai dans les forêts.
Je pensais que oui.
Les arbres dans les forêts pouvaient aussi partager des informations sous le sol.
Mais cela portait à controverse
et certains me pensaient folle.
J'ai eu beaucoup de mal à obtenir des fonds pour mes recherches.
Mais j'ai persévéré
et j'ai finalement conduit des expériences au fin fond de la forêt.
C'était il y a 25 ans.
J'ai cultivé 80 répliques de trois espèces :
du bouleau à papier, du pin de Douglas et du cèdre rouge de l'Ouest.
Je pensais que le bouleau et le pin seraient liés grâce à un réseau souterrain
mais pas le cèdre.
Il était dans son propre monde.
J'ai donc rassemblé mon matériel,
n'ayant pas d'argent, cela devait être bon marché.
Je suis allée dans un magasin de bricolage --
(Rires)
et j'ai acheté des sacs plastiques, du scotch, une toile d'ombrage,
un minuteur, une combinaison, un respirateur.
Puis j'ai emprunté des trucs high-tech à mon université :
un compteur Geiger, un compteur de scintillation,
un spectromètre de masse, des microscopes.
Puis j'ai pris des trucs très dangereux :
des seringues pleines d'un gaz radioactif, dioxyde de carbone marqué au carbone 14,
et des bouteilles haute pression
d'un isotope stable : du dioxyde de carbone marqué au carbone 13.
Mais j'avais une autorisation.
(Rires)
Et j'ai oublié des trucs,
des trucs importants : un insecticide,
un gaz poivré, les filtres pour le respirateur.
Eh bien.
Le premier jour, nous sommes allés sur place
et nous avons été chassés par un grizzly et ses oursons.
Je n'avais pas de gaz poivré.
C'est ainsi, la recherche forestière au Canada.
(Rires)
Je suis revenu le lendemain
et la mère grizzly et ses petits étaient partis.
Là, nous avons vraiment commencé.
J'ai enfilé ma combinaison,
mis mon respirateur
et puis
j'ai mis les sacs plastiques sur mes arbres.
J'avais mes énormes seringues
et j'ai injecté dans les sacs
mon isotope traceur fait de dioxyde de carbone gazeux.
D'abord le bouleau.
J'ai injecté du carbone 14, le gaz radioactif,
dans le sac du bouleau.
Puis pour le pin,
j'ai injecté l'isotope stable, le gaz de carbone 13 carbone dioxyde.
J'ai utilisé deux isotopes
car je me demandais
si la communication était bidirectionnelle entre les deux espèces.
Arrivée au dernier sac,
la 80ème réplique,
tout à coup la mère grizzly est réapparue.
Elle m'a poursuivie,
j'avais mes seringues au-dessus de la tête,
j'écrasais les moustiques et j'ai sauté dans la camionnette
et j'ai pensé :
« Cela explique les études en labo. »
(Rires)
J'ai attendu une heure.
C'était le temps nécessaire
pour que les arbres absorbent le CO2 par photosynthèse,
le transforment en sucres, l'envoient à leurs racines
et, peut-être, c'était une hypothèse,
transmettre ce carbone à leurs voisins, par le sous-sol.
L'heure passée,
j'ai baissé ma fenêtre
et vérifié si le grizzly était là.
Bien, elle est là-bas à manger des airelles.
Je suis sortie du camion et me suis mise au travail.
Je suis allée au premier sac de bouleau et j'ai enlevé le sac.
J'ai passé mon compteur Geiger sur ses feuilles.
Kkhh !
Parfait.
Le bouleau avait absorbé le gaz radioactif.
Puis, le moment de vérité.
Je suis allée jusqu'au pin.
J'ai enlevé son sac.
J'ai passé le compteur Geiger sur ses aiguilles
et j'ai entendu le plus beau des sons :
kkhh !
C'était le son du bouleau parlant au pin
et le bouleau disait : « Salut, puis-je t'aider ? »
Et le pin disait : « Oui, peux-tu m'envoyer du carbone ?
Parce qu'on m'a recouvert avec une toile d'ombrage. »
Je suis allée jusqu'au cèdre,
j'ai passé le compteur Geiger sur ses feuilles
et, comme je le pensais,
rien.
Le cèdre était dans son propre monde.
Il n'était pas connecté au réseau reliant le bouleau et le pin.
J'étais tellement excitée,
j'ai couru de plant en plant et j'ai vérifié les 80 répliques.
Les preuves étaient bien là.
Le C-13 et le C-14 me montraient
que le bouleau à papier et le pin de Douglas
avaient une conversation bidirectionnelle vivante.
Il s'avère qu'à cette période de l'année,
pendant l'été,
le bouleau envoyait plus de carbone au pin que le pin n'en envoyait au bouleau,
surtout si le pin était ombragé.
Dans les expériences suivantes, c'était le contraire,
le pin envoyait plus de carbone au bouleau que le bouleau n'en envoyait au pin
car le pin grandissait encore alors que le bouleau n'avait plus de feuilles.
Les deux espèces étaient interdépendantes,
comme le yin et le yang.
A ce moment, les pièces du puzzle se sont assemblées.
Je savais que j'avais fait une grande découverte
qui changerait notre vision
des interactions des arbres dans les forêts :
ils n'étaient pas seulement en compétition
mais en coopération.
J'avais des preuves solides
de cet important réseau de communications souterrain,
l'autre monde.
J'espérais et croyais vraiment
que ma découverte changerait notre pratique de la sylviculture,
quittant la coupe et le désherbage
pour aller vers des méthodes plus holistiques et durables,
des méthodes moins chères et plus pratiques.
A quoi pensais-je ?
J'y reviendrai.
Comment faisons-nous de la science
dans des systèmes complexes comme les forêts ?
En tant que scientifiques forestiers, nos recherches ont lieu en forêt
et, comme je l'ai dit, c'est difficile.
Nous devons savoir échapper à un ours.
Mais nous devons surtout persévérer
malgré les obstacles qui s'accumulent.
Nous devons suivre notre intuition et nos expériences
et poser les bonnes questions.
Nous devons rassembler nos données puis les vérifier.
J'ai conduit et publié des centaines d'expériences en forêt.
Certaines de mes plantations expérimentales ont 30 ans.
Vous pouvez vérifier.
La science forestière fonctionne ainsi.
J'aimerais parler de la science.
Comment le bouleau et le pin communiquaient-ils ?
Il s'avère qu'ils conversaient non seulement dans la langue du carbone
mais aussi avec du nitrogène, du phosphore,
de l'eau, des signaux de défense,
des produits chimiques alléliques et des hormones --
des informations.
Je dois vous dire qu'avant moi, les scientifiques pensaient
que cette symbiose souterraine mutualiste du nom de mycorhize
était impliquée.
Mycorhize signifie « racine champignon ».
Vous voyez leurs organes reproductifs en vous promenant en forêt.
Ce sont les champignons.
Mais les champignons ne sont que la partie visible de l'iceberg
car de ces pieds sortent des filaments fongiques formant un mycélium
et ce mycélium infecte et colonise les racines
de tous les arbres et plantes.
L'interaction des cellules fongiques et les racines
est un lieu d'échange de carbone pour les nutriments
et ce champignon obtient ces nutriments en grandissant dans le sol
et en recouvrant les particules du sol.
Le réseau est si dense qu'il peut y avoir des centaines de kilomètres de mycélium
en l'espace d'un seul pas.
Le mycélium connecte différents individus dans la forêt,
non seulement ceux de la même espèce mais aussi entre différentes espèces,
comme le bouleau et le pin,
cela fonctionne comme internet.
Comme tout réseau,
les réseau mycorhiziens ont des nœuds et des liaisons.
Nous avons créé cette carte en examinant les courtes séquences d'ADN
de chaque arbre et chaque champignon
dans une parcelle de forêt où il y a des pins de Douglas.
Dans ce schéma, les cercles représentent les pin de Douglas, ou les nœuds,
et les lignes représentent
les interconnexions fongiques, ou les liaisons.
Les nœuds les plus gros et les plus foncés sont les plus importants.
Nous les appelons arbres concentrateurs,
ou, plus affectueusement, les arbres mères
car ces arbres concentrateurs nourrissent les jeunes arbres,
ceux qui poussent dans les sous-bois.
Si vous voyez ces points jaunes,
ce sont les jeunes plants qui se sont installés dans le réseau
des vieux arbres mères.
Dans une forêt, un arbre mère peut être connecté à des centaines d'arbres.
Grâce à nos traceurs isotopes,
nous savons que les arbres mères
envoient leur excès de carbone aux plus petits plants
via le réseau mycorhizien.
Nous estimons que cela augmente les chances de survie des plants
par quatre.
Nous favorisons tous nos propres enfants,
et je me suis demandé si le pin de Douglas reconnaissait les siens,
comme la mère grizzly et ses petits.
Nous avons mis en place une expérience
et avons cultivé des arbres mères
avec des plants de la même espèce et d'autres espèces.
Il s'avère qu'ils reconnaissent les leurs.
Les mères arbres colonisent les leurs avec des réseaux mycorhiziens plus grands.
Ils leur envoient plus de carbone via le sous-sol.
En terme de racines, ils réduisent même la compétition
pour laisser de l'espace vital à leurs enfants.
Quand les arbres mères sont blessés ou mourants,
ils envoient des messages de sagesse à la nouvelle génération de plants.
Le traçage par isotope a permis
de tracer le déplacement du carbone d'un arbre mère blessé
le long de son tronc, vers le réseau mycorhizien
et vers les jeunes plants alentour,
pas seulement le carbone mais aussi les signaux de défense.
Ces deux composants
ont augmenté la résistance des jeunes plants aux stress futurs.
Les arbres se parlent !
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Au travers de conversations bidirectionnelles,
ils augmentent la résistance de toute la communauté.
Cela vous rappelle probablement nos propres communautés sociales
et nos familles,
enfin au moins certaines.
(Rires)
Revenons au point initial.
Les forêts ne sont pas juste un ensemble d'arbres,
ce sont des systèmes complexes avec des hubs et des réseaux
qui se chevauchent, connectent les arbres et leur permettent de communiquer,
leur fournissent des voies de rétroaction et d'adaptation
et c'est cela qui rend la forêt robuste :
le grand nombre d'arbres concentrateurs et de réseaux se chevauchant.
Mais elles sont aussi vulnérables,
vulnérables non seulement aux perturbations naturelles
comme les dendroctones qui préfèrent attaquer les gros arbres
mais aussi l'exploitation forestière et les coupes claires.
Vous pouvez ôter un ou deux arbres concentrateurs
mais il y a une limite à respecter
car les arbres concentrateurs ressemblent aux rivets d'un avion :
vous pouvez en enlever un ou deux et l'avion continuera de voler,
mais si vous en enlevez un de trop
ou celui qui maintient les ailes,
tout le système s'effondre.
Est-ce que ça a changé votre vision des forêts ?
(Public) Oui.
Cool.
Je suis contente.
Souvenez-vous de ce que j'ai dit que j'espérais de ma recherche :
que mes découvertes changeraient notre pratique de la sylviculture.
J'aimerais vérifier, 30 ans après, à l'ouest du Canada.
C'est à 100 kilomètres à l'ouest d'où nous sommes,
à la frontière du Parc National de Banff.
Il y a beaucoup de coupes claires.
Ce n'est pas intact.
En 2014, l'Institut des Ressources Mondiales a rapporté
que le Canada, au cours des 10 dernières années,
avait le taux de perturbation des forêts le plus élevé du monde
et vous auriez parié sur le Brésil.
Au Canada, le taux est de 3,6% par an.
D'après mes estimations, c'est quatre fois le taux acceptable.
La perturbation massive à cette échelle affecte les cycles hydrologiques,
dégrade l'habitat sauvage
et réémet des gaz à effet de serre dans l'atmosphère,
ce qui entraîne plus de perturbations et de dépérissement d'arbres.
Nous continuons aussi à planter une ou deux espèces
et éliminons les trembles et les bouleaux.
Ces forêts simplifiées manquent de complexité
et sont très vulnérables aux infections et aux insectes.
Alors que le climat change,
cela prépare le terrain
pour des événements tels que l'invasion du dendroctone de pin
qui a traversé l'Amérique du nord
ou cet énorme feu des derniers mois dans l'Alberta.
Je veux revenir à mon ultime question :
au lieu d'affaiblir nos forêts,
comment pouvons-nous les renforcer, les aider avec le changement climatique ?
L'avantage dans le fait que les forêts sont des systèmes complexes
est qu'elles ont une capacité gigantesque à se guérir seules.
Nos expériences récentes
ont montré que la coupe par trouées,
la rétention des arbres concentrateurs
et la régénération à une diversité d'espèces, de gènes et de génotypes,
permet à ces réseaux mycorhiziens de s'en remettre rapidement.
Avec cela en tête, je veux vous quitter en vous donnant quatre solutions simples.
Et nous ne pouvons pas dire qu'elles sont trop compliquées.
Un : nous devons tous aller en forêt.
Nous devons rétablir l'implication locale dans nos propres forêts.
La plupart de nos forêts
sont gérées de la même manière,
mais une bonne intendance des forêts
requiert la connaissance des conditions locales.
Deux : nous devons sauver les forêts primitives.
Ce sont des recueils de gènes, d'arbres mères et de réseaux mycorhiziens.
Cela signifie moins de coupe.
Je ne dis pas pas de coupe, mais moins.
Trois : quand nous coupons,
nous devons sauver l'héritage,
les arbres mères et les réseaux,
le bois et les gènes,
pour qu'ils puissent transmettre leur sagesse à la prochaine génération
afin qu'ils résistent aux futurs stress.
Nous devons défendre l'environnement.
Pour finir, quatre :
nous devons régénérer nos forêts avec une diversité d'espèces,
de génotypes et de structures
en plantant et en permettant la régénération naturelle.
Nous devons donner à Mère Nature les outils nécessaires
afin qu'elle puisse, grâce à son intelligence, se guérir.
Nous devons nous souvenir que les forêts ne sont pas un tas d'arbres
en compétition,
ils sont en coopération.
Revenons-en à Jigs.
La chute de Jigs dans les toilettes m'a montré cet autre monde
et a changé ma vision des forêts.
J'espère qu'aujourd'hui j'ai changé votre vision des forêts.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)